we got the stars to discuss their most
magical met gala moments
[Applause]
like shut down like an interstate to get
in there last year I do that every once
in a while and yeah
Katy's angel wings almost caused a red
carpet catastrophe nearly knocking over
her stylist but ever wonder where those
wings are now wings are property of
Donatella Versace a loner don't like
need to wear them again so where did the
gowns go after the stars wear them you
get to keep these dresses I wish would
not be amazing
no you never get to keep them you have
to give everything back I have to say
the winner will prouder than that collar
they let me keep that dress I think it's
the only one I've kept to be honest the
gown Sofia Vergara wore to the 2012 Met
Gala is on display at Madame Tussauds
Kim Kardashian's couch dress is in her
closet
Kim actually recycled theirs Yvonne she
looked for Halloween two years later
when she was pregnant with Saint saying
still fits
Rihanna's gown you know the one that
started all of those memes was recently
on display at a museum in Canada it took
two years to make awareness
[Music]
[Applause]